with us now from the hill Senator Marco
Rubio Republican out of Florida sir good
morning to you and thank you for your
time want to get to this this class
action lawsuit your response to how
they're trying to deal with Governor
DeSantis in a legal sense well think
about this okay people came into this
country illegally violating our laws
okay and the first thing they do is get
lawyers and use our laws to sue an
elected governor to sue a state I mean
just think about that they just got here
they're not even here legally they
didn't enter the country the proper way
and they're immediately in court
demanding rights and claims under our
laws this is outrageous what other
country in the world would that even be
allowed what other country in the world
would even tolerate that so I think this
is you know we have a this is not
immigration what we're seeing okay this
is mass migration that's a very
different thing and and but to think
about the fact that somebody just came
here illegally and within a week they're
in court and they have lawyers
representing them in court suing the
American government that who's lost they
just violated is is unbelievable it's
outrageous it angers me and it should
anger everybody President Biden got at
least one question on this let's watch
here
why is the Border more overwhelmed under
your watch Mr President because there
are three countries that are never have
there are fewer
fewer immigrants coming from Central
America and from Mexico
this is a totally different circumstance
what's on my watch now is Venezuela Cuba
and Nicaragua and the ability to send
them back to those States is not
rational
could you speak to that sir
well there's no doubt that those are
communist countries Cube has been a
communist country for 70 years I'm glad
he finally recognizes that since his
people in his administration and the
president he served under tried to argue
that they weren't or they weren't that
bad anymore and tried to get closer to
them on Venezuela he's the one that's
sending people to meet with Maduro and
try to cut a deal to buy more oil from
the guy so I don't know where why he's
so outreached by Nicaragua they don't do
anything but but it's not just from
those three countries it's from all over
the world I mean there are literally
people from over 100 different countries
entering the border crossing the border
it's an industry okay there are flights
from turkey that are bringing people
from Turkey in the Middle East into
Mexico into Cancun and then from there
crossing the border it's from everywhere
it's uncontrolled it's out of control
and the hypocrisy of all these
communities that say oh we welcome these
immigrants we want them here but within
24 hours Martha's Vineyard had deported
the immigrants to Cape Cod
sir we've spent billions over the past
20 years trying to make sure that a
terrorist doesn't get on an airplane
yet we just found out in the month of
August alone 12 arrests were made on the
FBI's terrorist watch list which brings
the total to 78 suspected terrorists
arrested so far this year
that's three times the number of the
last five years put together I will
remind you as if you need to know this
that only 19 hijackers pulled off 9 11.
but the problem is that those are the
ones we know about okay so most people
that are crossing the border they've all
been coached this is an industry so they
they coach you up these are the magic
words you have to say you turn yourself
into a border agent you say these magic
words you'll be released by the way with
a fake address no one's talking about
that DHS is now giving people migrants
if they don't have an address they give
them a fake address in the United States
but people are tearing themselves in if
you know you're a terrorist you're not
turning yourself in so of the 78 is but
a small sliver of what we suspect is a
much broader group of people linked to
groups in the Middle East of terrorism
but also terrorist groups in our
hemisphere the eln and the farc two
communist terrorists Narco trafficking
organizations in Colombia Venezuela
region there are people linked to that
in fact I think that's the single
largest group of terrorists that have
been apprehended that have been sent
here and what we don't even know and I
think we need to be looking into it
there's been reports on this is is there
a strategy here is Venezuela
deliberately are other countries
deliberately sending people here that
they believe will cause harm within the
United States we all also don't know the
answer to that but there's some
suspicion that that might be the case
none of this is going to be answered by
this administration because they don't
give they don't care they really
literally do not care
Senator thank you we appreciate your
time this morning we'll uh we're going
to hear from the president at the U.N a
little bit later I'm sure you'll have
thoughts on that so we'll stay in touch
thank you thank you Senator thank you hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now